The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw@mit.edu.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: I'll
start today with an animation.
I think most of
you have seen this.
Raise your hand if you haven't.
So some of you have not.
OK.
So I'm going to just play it.
This is London.
And you're going to
see different colors.
There's a legend right here
on this corner, lower left.
And blue stands
for some cardholder
in the London system that
has not yet been [AUDIO OUT]
or it's after the last
time that person was seen.
So it's a proxy for
home, essentially.
Bright green is going to
be a proxy for travel.
Not a proxy, it's going to mean
that this card is currently
in the TFL system in a bus
ride or in a train somewhere.
And then red will show anything
between trips that day.
So that's a proxy for work.
Or it could be a
proxy for shopping,
or restaurants, or
anything between travel.
So after the last
trip is completed,
and before the last trip ends.
So I'm just going to play this.
And hopefully this will
motivate the discussion,
the rest of the lecture.
So you can see the
time at the bottom.
Sorry.
So you see the morning rush, and
then people starting to work,
so it turns red.
That means most people
are between trips.
You see a lot of
buzz in the middle
of the city, middle of the day.
And then as we approach
the afternoon peak,
you start seeing
more green activity,
starting from the
center, going out.
And then some blue as
people reach their homes
and won't travel again that day.
Still a lot of activity in
some centers, especially
in the center of London,
a lot of travel still.
And then past midnight,
you sort of see Soho,
so you know where to
hang out in London.
OK?
OK.
So before we continue, any
questions about that video?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it seemed
to me that some of the dots
were actually not
moving along the lines.
Is that deliberate?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
So yeah.
In this video--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
--there are multiple ways--
AUDIENCE: --magnitude?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah.
So there are multiple ways of
generating this visualization.
And the one that my
colleague used to make this--
and by the way,
this video was made
by my colleague, Jay Gordon.
You'll see in the last slide,
the references to his papers
and to the website with
a link to the video.
So yeah, for each stage--
and we'll talk about
what the stage is.
For each of these
trips, for now, you
could do it a straight line or
you could really interpolate
geographically along the line.
And in some aspects,
the straight line one
is showing isochromes almost.
So it's easier to understand,
visually, the OD pairs
when you do it that way.
But both have value.
And you could look
at it both ways.
Any other questions about
this animation visualization?
OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah.
Let's talk about
how we made that.
And so what goes into
creating this visualization,
and what data was used for it.
So today's lecture is on
origin destination and transfer
inference.
We abbreviate that ODX, O for
origin, D for destination,
X being more graphical, two
lines crossing in the middle.
So your opportunity to
transfer or interchange.
And if we use the British
term for transfers,
that would be interchange.
So what's common in
all of these methods
is that we're going to
be basing these methods
on automatically-collected data.
So we're going to
be using AFC, AVL,
APC, instead of manual surveys.
There are ways of estimating
origin destination matrices
in the traditional way,
with manual surveys.
You go out, and you distribute
colored cards and collect them,
and you can do this.
So a little bit about that
when we talk about surveys
and survey planning.
Some of these methods can be
used to infer destinations
in open systems.
So open systems are
like the bus and rail,
here in Boston, where you tap
in, but you don't tap out.
If you look at the rail system
in London or in Washington DC,
that's a closed system,
where you tap in and tap out.
And therefore, the
OD pair for each trip
is given in that
part of the system.
It also infers transfers.
So we'll talk about
why this is important.
One of the caveats
of these methods
is that they only look at the
current public transportation
demand.
So if you want a model of all of
the demand that could be there,
the latent demand included,
this does not look at that.
So just be aware.
And also, specifically, one
of the models we will look at,
it can't infer destinations
for every transaction.
Some of that makes sense.
If you see a card
only one time a day,
then you don't necessarily
have information
to infer destination
or transfers.
That also happens with
cash transactions,
which cannot be tracked
using a smart card.
There's fare evasion.
So some people might
jump into a bus
and not interact
with the fare system,
so we can't capture
that directly.
And then there's
trips on other modes.
So part of the logic applying
to destinations and transfers
will, essentially, assume that
the people are mostly traveling
with public transportation.
And they're not going to
take Uber or a long bike ride
in between.
So we will look at
that more in detail.
Most of these methods have
been validated with surveys,
with good results.
And they need to be scaled
up because they don't
make inferences for every card.
If you want the full demand,
you need to scale it up
to the full demand.
We'll talk about scaling.
Questions?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] but
with London, fare evasion,
that's not a big problem, right?
Or is--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
I don't know.
AUDIENCE: All right.
GABRIEL
SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: I don't
have information about that.
So it could be fare
evasion, or it could be--
you might have a pass
and hop onto the bus,
and technically, it
wouldn't be fare evasion.
But it is non-interaction,
so that would still
be counted here as fare evasion.
AUDIENCE: The more open
a system, the more people
will manage to evade.
So I saw a number, then,
the Boston commuter rail,
they estimate 14%.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, that
number's a lie, but yes.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
But that's--
AUDIENCE: --a lot or--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, 70% of people
pay with a pass, so it's--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Right.
So there, they are using
fare evasion more overtly.
It is high, though, because
the train attendants
don't manage to collect
tickets from everyone.
And there are ways to
game the system, where
you can activate a ticket
only if the fare inspector is
approaching you.
So that's a flaw in the system.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah.
So more generally, when we talk
about data collection systems--
we've seen the key
ones, AVL, AFC, APC.
I think we're all familiar
with how these look.
Does anybody have questions on
any of these systems right now?
You were looking at some
data in your homework.
Do you have a question?
AUDIENCE: No.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: OK.
So they can be used
for many things.
And so if you look
at supply and demand,
they both produce
automatically-collected data.
So on the demand side, we
have the fare transactions
of the AFC system.
On the supply side,
you have the vehicle
tracking with AVL system.
You have APC as well.
So they can be sent to some
server or data warehouse
and used for many things.
It could be used for
offline functions.
So performance
measurement is one example
of that, where you want
to measure reliability,
running times, et cetera.
It could be used for service
and operations planning.
And then it can also
be used in real-time.
So you could use some
of this information
to generate customer
information, which feeds back
to demand.
You could send alerts
saying the trains are
being delayed right now.
Expect a longer wait.
And that could, in
fact, influence demand.
It could make some people
not take a particular trip
or wait if they get
it on their phone.
And then on the supply
side, the information
can be used to control service.
So you might actually
affect supply
by changing the departure times.
And that would affect
the data that is being
generated from the supply side.
So there's a feedback loop.
In this lecture, we
will focus on only one
aspect of this
framework, and that
is origin destination matrices.
Origin destination
matrices [AUDIO OUT]
one of the key inputs
to service planning.
They are the key demand
input to service planning.
You need them to figure out
where people want to go.
And it's just the
data that expresses
where people want to go.
And you should try
to design your system
to match that demand.
So it used to be that we
had to use manual surveys.
They were expensive.
They didn't cover all the
times or places very well.
And now, with all
these automated data
collection systems, we can infer
some of the origin destination
matrices from the data.
And that's what we
want to understand.
How does it happen?
What can we do?
How can we do it?
So OD matrix estimation can
happen at different levels.
One way of looking at it
is to think about route
level versus network level.
So route level, we're
talking about one bus line.
And we want to look up the
trips made in the one bus line
and understand where
people get on and off.
That's route level.
So if you have two routes
here, route one, route two,
we might notice or
estimate that a person
boards here and alights here.
Some of the people
doing that OD pair
may, in fact,
continue on route two.
They might transfer
to route two.
So what's the drawback?
Or why would it be
important to know
the transfer to route two and
the destination on route two?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Or is it irrelevant?
Is it just cool?
Or--
AUDIENCE: Maybe the
destination of the route two
is the real destination
of the person's trips
because if he goes
to work, for example,
the work will be at the
end of the route two.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Right.
So the real destination, the
place where the person actually
wants to go, might be on the
destination route two, and not
on the destination at route one.
So this might be--
the only reason why the
person is alighting there
is because that's
the only way-- that's
sort of a function of the
network of the supply you
provide.
So if there were a direct
route from the first origin
to the last destination,
perhaps they would prefer that.
And for service
planning, you want
to know what people want to do.
That's what demand is.
So we want network level.
So we go from unlinked
trips to linked trips.
That's part of
what we want to do.
At the network level, we
are looking at all the buses
and the rail system.
So again, that's
what we want to do.
We'll look at both kinds
of OD matrix estimation
in this lecture.
Let's start with one
of the simpler cases.
Consider a bus having
APC and only APC.
So APC data looks like this.
You have timestamps,
you have a bus ID,
you have a route ID, a
trip ID, some information
about direction,
perhaps, and then
counts at each stop of
how many people get on
and how many people get off,
boardings and alightings.
And, of course, a stop
ID, or a stop name,
or something like that.
So you can aggregate that across
trips or do it at a trip level,
and count how many people
get on at each stop,
and how many people
get off at each stop.
These are called control totals
in the context of scaling.
So you might be aggregating
across days, for example,
for a 30-minute
period, and count
how many people are
getting on at each stop
and getting off at each stop.
And then what we
want to estimate,
knowing how many people get
on and off at each stop,
is the origin
destination matrix.
That is the cells
inside of this matrix
saying how many people get on at
stop one and off at stop three.
We're showing here, 10.
Now you may notice that
the matrix here, it doesn't
necessarily match the totals.
So here we have 35 and
237, and the target is 40.
So we have to scale
it up a little bit.
Here, we have 30 people
getting off at stop two,
and we only have 25.
So that number is wrong.
We need to scale up.
So what we're going
to look at now
is a procedure called iterative
proportional fitting that
estimates, given some control
totals, what the origin
destination matrix is.
This is known as biproportional
fitting or matrix scaling
as well.
And we start with some initial
matrix or some seed matrix
here in the center.
The value of that seed
matrix is important.
It affects the solution.
So having an
accurate seed matrix
improves the accuracy
of the final estimate.
If you don't have
an idea, then you
could certainly initialize
that seed matrix with all ones,
and it will produce an output.
But it may not be the best
output or the most accurate
result.
So it has been shown that
if all the values provided
in the matrix are
strictly positive--
and here I am excluding what
we call structural zeros, so
all the cells in which people
could actually be traveling.
Here we are showing a route
with four stops, A, B, C, D.
And we have a matrix
showing how many people go
from A to B, from A to C, from A
to D, from B to C, from B to C,
and from C to D.
Those are the only
possible OD pairs.
Nobody is going to go from A to
A because that's the same stop,
so that's not a valid trip.
And we're only looking
at one direction,
so anything below
that diagonal would
be in the opposite direction.
And we're not including
it in this example.
So what we want to do is start
off with adding up each row,
adding up each column, so
we have total alightings
and total boardings.
I want them to match boardings,
and match target alightings,
or the control totals.
Questions?
AUDIENCE: What are the
control totals again?
GABRIEL
SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: They're
counts of boardings and counts
of alightings at each stop.
And they can, in this
example, come from APC.
AUDIENCE: That's
what come from APC.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
So what we do, the algorithm
for iterative
proportional fitting,
it calculates a scaling
factor for each row.
We start with rows.
And we say, well we need
to scale up everything
on the first row by 40 over
3, so that that number adds up
to 40.
And you calculate the
scaling factor for each row
and apply it to the
cells in the matrix.
And of course, the sum
of cells column-wise
is not going to add up
to the target alightings.
So the second step is to
apply the same procedure
on the columns.
And now we realize,
well, we need
to apply a scaling
factor of 30 over 13.3
to get B to add up to 30.
And you do the same
for each column.
And now the columns
sum up perfectly,
but the rows don't anymore.
So now we go back and
repeat the process.
And we go to the
rows and the columns.
I've put it in all the
slides so you can actually
repeat this in your spreadsheet
program, if you want.
It has been shown that if
all the non-structural values
of the cells in that
matrix are not zero,
and then they are positive,
then it will converge.
And it will converge to the
maximum likelihood estimate,
of the best possible
estimate, given your seed
and given your control totals.
So you can apply
this if you ever
have a situation where
you have control totals,
but not the origin
destination matrix.
And that's one example
of-- that would
be having APC and nothing else.
Any questions on this method?
We're to see it again in
a different application
later in this lecture.
AUDIENCE: Is it guaranteed to
converge to the correct value?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Well, what is correct?
It may not be the
truth, if that's
what you mean by correct.
So it's the best
estimate of the truth,
given the information provided.
AUDIENCE: How might it
converge to something
that isn't correct?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Your
seed matrix might be wrong.
Or there might be aggregation
errors, for example.
So if you start with all
ones, that's clearly not true.
And this is the best
possible estimate,
given your starting assumption
that all of the pairs
are equally likely, and then
adjusting from there, right?
And then I mentioned
structural zeros.
So if you have a
non-structural zero,
say that with
onboard survey, you
collected OD demand only
for a couple of trips
and used that to
seed the matrix.
And let's say that first
some of these OD pairs,
you didn't observe a single
person taking that trip.
So you say, well, in
the seed, I have a zero,
but that's a non-structural
zero because--
it is a structural zero, rather.
So this value, some people
might be taking the OD pair.
And if you seed it
a zero, then you
can't scale it up above zero.
So in this case, you would
not converge necessarily.
And you certainly
would not converge
to the maximum
likelihood estimate.
OK?
AUDIENCE: I was going to ask how
you get a better seed matrix,
but you--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
So with any kind--
we'll talk about
other methods for ODX,
so for estimating origin
destination matrices.
Manual surveys is one example.
Any knowledge that you have
about what OD pairs are busiest
should help.
So you could do on-off counts
with the traditional way
if the only thing
you have is this.
And we've talked about
surveys extensively.
AUDIENCE: So just
to [INAUDIBLE],,
APC is the target
boarding [INAUDIBLE]..
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah.
So over some number of trips--
and this is a toy
example, clearly.
Over some number of
trips, you counted
40 people boarding
at A, and 30 people
alighting at B, and so forth.
So you want the
cells to match that.
OK?
So you could do this
in Excel, or you
could write your own
little function to do this.
It amplifies errors
in the seed matrix.
You're scaling
up, so if you have
errors in your seed matrix,
they will be scaled up too.
Just be aware of that.
So what about if
we don't have APC?
What if we only
have a AFC and AVL?
So now we don't
have control tools.
AFC might give you boardings,
but not alightings.
So what are the ways of
scaling up with that?
You have different systems,
and it depends on the system.
So if you look at TFL in London,
we said AFC there is closed,
so the origin station pairs
are given by the rail system
because people have
to tap in and tap out.
On bus, however,
people only tap in.
So there, you would have to
apply this inference method.
Here in the MBTA, both
bus and rail are open.
You tap in.
You don't tap out.
So we have to infer
destinations in rail and in bus.
And then in some more
advanced systems,
a lot of information, including
transfer information, is given.
Seoul is one example of that.
AUDIENCE: How is that different?
They--
AUDIENCE: They tap
in [INAUDIBLE]..
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
They tap in between--
yeah.
So that there's an
interchange tap.
AUDIENCE: They actually
have to tap out to leave--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
And by the way,
in some parts of London's
network, that is true.
You tap to prove that
you were transferring.
There might be a fare
advantage to doing that.
So control totals.
So here in Boston, with the MBTA
buses, some portion of buses
have APC, but not all of them.
So you could use the
first method applied
to only a fraction of
vehicles and then scale up
to all vehicles.
That's one possibility.
Or you need something else.
In London, they don't have
APC, at least not widespread.
And they do have the
ticketing machine.
So in theory,
drivers are supposed
to push a button if somebody
boards, and they don't tap.
Do they actually do it?
Not clear to what
extent the drivers
comply with that instruction.
And then gates and rail gates.
So tapping in or out of
the subway system there,
there's a counter.
So it counts people
passing through.
So if somebody goes in through
a gate and out some other place,
and we don't know
exactly what they did,
the total number of people
at each node in the system
can be counted.
And we can use that
information to scale up.
So we'll talk about that later.
So it depends on the context.
Let's start with origin
inference, the first letter
in ODX is origin inference.
So we're looking at a bus,
which has one stop and then
another stop.
And if we match the AFC
transaction times to the AVL
stop visit times, we can put
them on the same timeline
and realize, well,
there was a tap
right after that AVL system said
that the bus left that stop.
It's very close,
however, to that stop.
So let's assume that the tap--
maybe the bus pulled
out and started moving,
and the person was
finding the card.
But you still tap-- it
if it's close enough,
let's assign it to that stop.
AUDIENCE: Just a
second, are there
systems where the AFC is
connected to the AVL directly?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Are there systems
where the AFC
connected to the AVL?
Yes.
In London, they do that now.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
They didn't when we started
with this, but they do it now.
AUDIENCE: Because I
know from the process
that you and Neema
wrote for Chicago, where
you had to connect the AFC to
the AVL, it was a headache.
But it seems to me like
it shouldn't be that way.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Well, remember these systems--
AUDIENCE: It should have
an AV feeder into AFC.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: So
it's starting to move that way,
but none of these systems
were put in to capture data.
None of them.
APC is the only one, actually.
So APC was put in to
collect data and not
have to do all these surveys
because that's expensive.
But AFC was put in to
collect fares, and avoid
theft of fare revenue, and
simplify the duties of drivers,
improve safety.
So there are many
advantages to it.
Smart cards have the
advantage of having passes
and all these things, so many
advantages to an AFC system.
AVL was for safety.
If there was an
emergency on the bus,
the driver could hit a
button, and the police
and the ambulances
could be dispatched
to the location of the bus.
That's why it was started.
Later on, it started being
used for management as well.
Data collection of how many
miles of service you provided,
which is a requirement
for the NDT reporting.
So aggregate level reporting.
But none of these systems
were put in thinking,
oh, we're going to
estimate origin destination
matrices with them.
So that's something that
has come after the fact.
Now that people are
thinking about that, yes.
We start seeing, can we
hook up these two systems,
which might be from
different vendors,
and make them talk
to each other?
So London does that now.
So if you see some tap that
is very far away, in time,
from any stop, you might not
be able to infer the origin.
If it's close or between the
reported arrival and departure,
we match that transaction
to that origin.
Simple, right?
So in London, we did that.
This is Jay Gordon's
thesis, which is
referenced in the last slide.
Looking at 10 weekdays.
Oyster is the AFC
system in London.
And so 96% of boarding
locations were
inferred within plus
or minus five minutes.
And that was one of the
thresholds they looked at.
28% were exactly between the
reported arrival and departure.
So some tolerance
before the arrival
and after the departure
from each stop
was needed to infer a
large portion of these.
All right?
Simple.
Destinations, that's
the next step.
So we have origins.
It's a rail system, you tap in.
It just tells you
I'm gate number blah,
and that is at some station.
If it's a bus, you can join
AVL with AFC, and you get it.
Now let's look at destinations.
So there are different methods
for inferring destinations.
[AUDIO OUT] AFC and AVL.
And one of the simplest methods,
or the family of methods,
is the closest stop assumption.
So what are the key assumptions?
We start by saying that the
destination of each trip
segment is close to the origin
of the following trip segment.
So in other words, that is
true, physically, right?
You have to move
somehow through space.
So we, further, now assume
that that movement is happening
mostly through the public
transportation network,
and that no trips on other
modes are being made.
So if you go from home
to work in the morning,
and you have to then--
say that you work, and then
at the end of the workday,
you go back home.
We see that your next
origin is the stop
across the street from where
you got off, hopefully.
So we'll look at which stop was
closest on the trip you boarded
to the next origin.
And we'll infer that
is the destination.
If it's a rail system--
that's what we
show here in blue.
So we have an origin
on this bus line.
We want to infer which
of the downstream stops
is a destination.
And then we look
at the next trip,
and the next trip
started at T, the target.
And we want to get as close
as possible to the target.
So we'll say that
the destination
is D, if the distance between
the D and T is small enough.
Because if it's
three kilometers,
we might say we have no clue.
This person may have moved
with a different mode.
And therefore, this
assumption of closest stop
may not apply in that case.
So in those few
cases, we won't make
an inference of destination.
If it's rail, so two
rail lines, and you
may be able to change between
lines behind the gate,
then closest stop
is the same station
that you next enter
because that's the closest.
So if it's a bus-- so you may
have boarded the Red Line here
and somehow gotten
to the Blue Line.
We don't know that
yet, but we observe
that the next tap
is at a bus, then
we find which station
on the rail network
is closest to that bus stop.
And that's the inference.
That's destination.
So this is the simplest method
for destination inference.
Any questions with
the closest stop rule
and that inference method?
Here's an example of one
card with four trips.
It's a time-space
diagram of sorts.
So we start the day
here in the morning,
and we maybe observe a
boarding at this line.
This person, in reality,
transferred to the second trip.
So we don't know that
at first, but we do see
the origin and the second trip.
So we find which of these stops
was closest to that origin
and, we say that's destination.
And likewise, from the
trip leading to work,
and from the trip returning
from work-- work, school,
whatever it is--
we find the closest one, and
we say that's destination.
And we just keep doing that.
What happens at
the end of the day?
There's no next one, right?
So what do we do?
AUDIENCE: If a
person gets on a bus
that does go to where they
started, if the last bus--
let's talk about
bus for a second.
If it leads back to
where they started,
then we can assume that they--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Right.
So that's the key assumption.
They key assumption
is that the person
returns to the first
place seen that day.
Another option is to
look at the AFC system
and see what is the next
place of origin the next day,
if you have that information.
Both things are possible.
OK?
AUDIENCE: But if they get
on the last bus of the day,
does not [INAUDIBLE].
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Well then you
can't make an inference.
So if they get on--
the question was,
what happens if they
get on, say, a bus.
And none of the downstream
stops of the origin
get close to the first
origin of that day
or the first origin
of the next day,
then we can't make an inference.
So we leave that destination
uninferred for now.
All right?
So there are some tests.
We talked about distance.
Time is another one.
So there's different
ways of looking at this.
In London, when Jay
Gordon did this,
he got an entrance
rate of about 75%.
Here's a distribution
of speed between station
exit and inferred bus alighting
or subsequent station entry.
So very slow speeds here.
This goes up way
higher than 800.
What does that show?
This is meters per hour, so
if you move zero or, say,
one meter per hour,
what does that imply?
AUDIENCE: Someone
was taking a bus?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Who are those people?
Emily?
AUDIENCE: People who get off
at, say, a tube stop and then
go to work--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Go to work for eight hours.
AUDIENCE: --for eight hours.
And then--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
And then next boarding
is right across the
street, 8 hours later.
So those are people
who are between trips.
And then to the right,
here, we have something sort
of bell-shaped, with some
distribution, quite wide.
These are in the range
of walking speeds.
So it checks with what we
know, and what we infer.
Here is a distribution
of distance
between subsequent
tap and closest
stop on the current route.
So how far away that
you walk to the target
from your destination,
in other words.
And there's a cutoff.
If this were too far, we would
not want to make an inference.
But you can see that most people
have quite short distances.
So that's good.
That means that our inference
is more likely to be true.
OK?
And you have some details here.
So in the case of London,
there was a comparison
of the origins and destinations
produced by this algorithm,
with the bus OD survey,
which is a manual survey.
And it compared favorably.
One thing with BODS, of
course, it had the biases
that a manual survey has.
So it seems that BODS
underestimated ridership
during the peak periods, where
it was maybe harder to count.
Sometimes the BODS
return rates were low.
We saw some of the reasons
for biases in manual surveys.
If it's a very full
bus, people are
less likely to return a survey.
Or if you are a person who is
getting off at the next stop,
you are less likely
to answer the survey.
So BODS was, of course,
subject to those biases.
And essentially, the people
who were doing this validation
were happy with the
inference method.
Now what happens in
rail in Boston, say?
It's an open system.
So you can apply the
nearest node method.
But you have a complication
in Boston, the Green Line.
So the Green Line is--
if you take it in the
branches, you board, and then
you tap into the vehicle.
So it looks like a bus
from the fare standpoint.
And then you could end up
anywhere on the rail network.
So it's a little harder
to make an inference
of where you get off in that
case, especially going back.
Going back to the
branch, it's not clear.
Besides that, there
are some other reasons
to try more sophisticated
destination entrance methods.
We know that it may not always
be the case that the nearest
station in the rail system is
actually the alighting station.
There are some cases where
you wouldn't take an extra 15
minutes to get a
little bit closer.
And you are willing
to walk and make
a compromise between those two.
So the minimum cost path
method is an improvement
over the closest stop method.
What we do there is
we look at-- here's
the origin tap location,
the entry to the system.
And we, essentially,
explore using a minimum cost
formulation, a dynamic
programming approach.
All the feasible
paths that the person
could take to their next
tap location, the target.
And that includes walking links
from any possible exit station.
So we then use a
generalized cost equation
to assign a cost to
each of these paths,
with relative disutility
weights on each component.
So waiting is more
than vehicle time.
Walking is more
than waiting time.
We've seen these
equations before.
And now we have a
list of paths, and we
assume that the person
took the one that
minimized their disutility.
Their combined,
generalized disutility--
avoiding walking,
in-vehicle time transfers,
all those things.
So in this case,
perhaps the person
prefers to get off
of the Red Line
and walk to the next location.
You could think of
this as the Red Line
from Kendall to Park Street.
And then the next entry
is at, say, a bus stop
close to Boylston Street.
You could transfer to the Green
Line and take it one stop,
or you might decide
it's a nice walk.
I'm going to walk.
I'm not going to wait
for the Green Line.
And then some possible
paths take you
way far from your next
location, so they are pruned.
They're not included.
So what happens if we
compare the two methods?
What's your intuition?
Or what do you think
happens if we compare
the results of nearest node with
this more sophisticated method?
What percentage of
destinations do you
think will be inferred
at a different place?
Is it close to 5?
Close to 50?
Close to 25?
10%?
AUDIENCE: 5%.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: 5%?
AUDIENCE: What percent of the
destinations will be inferred
or will not be inferred?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Will be inferred differently.
AUDIENCE: Oh, will be
inferred differently.
5%.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Five?
OK.
So that's actually close.
I actually don't think I wrote
the results, which is good.
So let's look at two examples.
It is close to 5%, in fact.
Some of the differences
in the Boston network
are clear improvements
in the accuracy.
I'll give you one
example of that.
Some people go
from Forest Hills,
and then their next
tap is at Copley.
So the walk between Back Bay
and Copley is five minutes,
and it's a nice walk.
If you use nearest
node, you have
to remain on the rail line.
And you have to transfer either
at Downtown Crossing to the Red
and then at Park
Street to the Green
or go to Haymarket and
transfer it to the Orange Line.
That's a 20-minute,
25-minute ordeal.
AUDIENCE: For a walk from
Downtown across to Park Street,
that's--
AUDIENCE: Sure, but then you
are not following the method.
AUDIENCE: Oh, you don't
[INAUDIBLE] transfer?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah.
So this is a case where the
minimum cost approach says,
yeah, you get off the
Back Bay, and you walk.
So yes, it's an improvement.
There are some other cases--
AUDIENCE: What was the
person destination?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Well,
we don't know destination.
We're inferring destination.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
And what we know
is that they get on at
Copley the next time.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, but was
that their afternoon trip?
Or was that their--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
It's a morning trip.
They go from Forest Hills.
AUDIENCE: So both Forest Hills
and Copley were morning taps?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Oh, I don't know.
Copley might have been
the afternoon tap.
AUDIENCE: It doesn't
really matter
if it was in the afternoon.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
But then why would
a person get on--
AUDIENCE: The question
is where do they
get off the Orange Line.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Right.
We're trying to infer the
destination when they board
the Orange Line in the morning.
AUDIENCE: But the
time gap also matters.
Forest Hills--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: We
are making an assumption that
people [AUDIO OUT]
too far from their--
AUDIENCE: But I--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
--destination
in a non-public
transportation mode.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
That's one
of the assumptions
in this method
and in the previous
method as well.
AUDIENCE: But I'm still
troubled by the time gap.
Was Copley and afternoon tap?
Or was it--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
It could have been.
There are many
people who do this.
AUDIENCE: It makes
a difference--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
So there
are many people who do this.
So there are some
people who do it
close in time and some people
who do it in the evening,
after they leave work.
So I'm giving you an example
of one origin target pair.
And I would say it's
a marked improvement.
It's certainly not the case
that the person goes all the way
to Haymarket and turns around.
OK.
The other example is less clear.
So somebody-- an OD pair
starting at Maverick,
and then the next tap
is at Downtown Crossing.
So obviously, the
closest node assumption
is that you transfer
at State Street
and take the Orange
Line one stop.
That's actually not too bad.
The algorithm-- and first,
for a lot of these people,
that you get off
at State Street,
and you walk about four
minutes, and if you
look at Google
directions, Google
will say that's
what you should do.
The transfer to the
Orange Line would take
six minutes, instead of four.
So it's very close.
And it depends on
the weather that day.
people's preference.
It might depend on
real-time information
about whether the
train is right here,
and I can run, or
arriving in one minute,
or if it's 10 minutes away.
So this is more
subtle, more nuanced.
And I wouldn't say that
was an improvement.
So part of the 5% is
clear improvement,
and another part of it is,
well, it might be an improvement
or not.
It depends on
people's preferences.
So if we look at the
distribution of the results
from destination in this
case, 70% of destinations
were inferred.
And then we have different
reasons why we can't infer it.
So for 16%, there was
no target location.
That means there was no other
tap that day, essentially.
So there was no target.
For 8% of them, there
was another target,
but it was very far.
So somehow, the person went to
another bus stop in the system,
and it was far away
from any rail station.
So we're not so
comfortable, in that case,
saying that the destination
is close to the next tap.
So we will not make an
inference for those people.
Some paths were non-feasible.
So that means that
the algorithm did not
find any path that made
it to the target on time
to make the next.
So that could be about data.
It could be a number of things.
There are some assumptions
about how quickly people
can access trains and hop.
So many things can go into that.
Yeah, and so forth.
And then unknown origin, so
errors in the data, et cetera.
OK?
And the inference probabilities,
the total ones are shown here.
So the blue line is overall
destination entrance rates,
so I said close to 70%.
That's what you see
on the blue line.
It dips a little bit on
weekends because there
are fewer taps and
maybe more walking
between taps or between trips.
For rail, it's a little
higher than the general.
For bus, shown in yellow,
it's a little lower.
And if you take
away the part that
didn't have a second tap or a
tap after that the transaction,
then it goes up to closer
to 90%, not quite 90%.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Does this include
only people who tapped?
Or does this also include
people who paid cash?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: So
these numbers in this slide
are everyone.
If the person is cash, then they
are not counted on the red line
because they wouldn't have
an inferable destination.
But certainly, the bus line
does include cash transactions.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
And that's
one of the reasons
why it's lower.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] target
location on the last slide
includes cash transactions?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: So
this was only for the rail.
Sorry, this is for
the whole system,
but the two examples that I
gave here, I was looking at--
I quoted 5%
difference, and that's
a case study where I compared
rail transactions, not
bus transactions.
So that's the one
thing to have in mind.
But yeah, this is overall
destination inference
in the MBTA, and this as well.
Different ways of looking at it.
AUDIENCE: So if you
paid cash, you'd
be in the no target range.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yes.
And you could infer an
origin for that person,
but not a destination, so you
leave that trip uninferred
destination for now.
OK.
We've covered O and D. Let's
move to X, transfer inference.
We talked about why transfer
inference is so important.
We also call this
interchange inference.
Interchange is a term preferred
in London by the British.
In the US, we say transfer.
So we have seen
this diagram before.
But now there are
these blue boxes
surrounding both, say, the
morning pair and the afternoon
pair.
So the inference
we want to make now
is whether this first
trip was connected
to the second with a transfer.
Or whether, in fact, the
person was doing something else
in between those two trips, and
this was the actual intended
destination of that passenger.
And that's an important
question for the reasons
we talked about earlier.
These are some definitions
for your reference.
A journey, in this
subject, is everything
that is accomplished
from the real origin
to the real destination
of the person,
including transfers and,
possibly, multiple fare
payments.
A fare stage, not
included in the slide,
is everything that you do
in a single fare payment.
So it could involve
behind-the-gate transfers,
or it could be one bus ride.
Transfers are transfers
between stages.
So they link segments
of a journey.
How do we do this linking?
This is also from Jay
Gordon's thesis, which
is referenced in the back.
We look at a series of
three kinds of conditions--
temporal conditions,
logical conditions,
and spatial conditions.
Temporal conditions,
say, how much time
happened between the
inferred destination
and the next origin,
the inferred origin.
If that was a very long time,
and the distance was short,
then the person might have
been doing something else.
So we can't necessarily assume
that this was a transfer.
We also look at bus wait time.
So what if the
distance was short?
A long time happened [AUDIO OUT]
of next bus or every 20
minutes, and the person
had to wait that long?
Well, that is also considered.
So if we look and see
that that next bus passed
after a reasonable time allowed
to get to the next stop.
Or how many buses passed?
Maybe you want to
allow one, just in case
that bus is very full and
can't take that person.
So these are the considerations
in temporal conditions.
Spatial conditions, you want
to look at maximum interchange
distance, assuming that
a person can actually
do a transfer that is two
kilometers long, for example.
You probably would be
doing something else,
if that's the case.
And we look at circuity, so
circuity at the journey level
and between stages.
A circuitous journey
is one that ends very
close to where you started.
So if you infer
transfers, and you
end up back where you
started, then somewhere
in that chain of stages,
there must have not
been a real transfer.
There must have been a
non-transportation activity.
So therefore, you can't really
infer that all of that chain
is linked with transfers.
And then circuity
between stages.
So if you, for example,
board the same bus line
going backwards, even
if the time was short,
and the distance was short,
you may have seen your friend
and given your friend something,
and then hopped on the bus
again.
So it might have been
a quick transfer.
And therefore, we want to
look at circuity to infer
if that was a transfer or not.
Logical conditions, I actually
gave an example of that right
now.
So if you're entering the
same station you get off at,
or you take the
same bus line, then
that shouldn't be a
transfer because you could
have stayed on the same bus.
One example of
that breaking would
be a bus being taken out of
service or something like this.
So you could consider not to
make that logical condition
more accurate.
In many cases when that
happens, though, people
are not asked to tap again.
So take that with
a grain of salt.
Questions about these
assumptions and the tests
that we impose?
So essentially, if all
of these tests pass,
we say, yes, this is a transfer.
If one of them doesn't pass,
we say, we're not sure.
It could have been or maybe not.
And therefore, this will be
a conservative assumption
about whether these two stages
are linked as one journey.
Here is in London, the results.
So about 2/3 were one stage,
about 1/4 were two stages,
and then about 10% were
more than two stages.
And here's a
distribution of duration
of journey from first
origin to last destination,
instead of the
unlinked trip time.
This includes transfer
time in between.
So very powerful for
service planning.
There was a comparison with
the London travel diary survey,
little tedious.
And it lined up quite well, but
there were some differences.
So if we look at people
reporting that they only
took one journey on the day
they were queried about,
it lined up very well.
If you then look
at two or more, it
turns out that a lot of people
in LTDS say that they took two,
but they may have taken more.
And they're just
simplifying the reporting.
That's one
possibility of errors.
And it is a known
bias in surveys
that people to try to help you
out by saying what I usually
do, instead of what I did
yesterday, or things like that.
So percent of cardholders,
shown on the second graph,
and the number of stages per
journey, similar pattern.
So in LTDS, you tend
to have fewer people.
Well, yeah, here we have more
people inferred with one stage,
so no transfer.
But if you look at two or
more, a similar pattern
emerges where people might be
reporting two and, in fact,
it might have been more or less.
So in this case, the bias
is towards more direct trips
on the inferred side, versus
the questionnaire side.
OK?
So it didn't validate perfectly.
But there were some
known issues with LTDS.
London has since decided
that ODX is more accurate.
Now they continue
LTDS because LTDS
is useful for other
things, like asking
about social demographics,
and trip purpose,
and things like that.
That doesn't obviate
the need for LTDS,
but it might reduce the need
to have as many LTDS surveys.
Scaling.
So we've done ODX,
and we've inferred
a percentage of destinations--
or we've inferred destinations
for a percentage of
transactions, not all of them.
And we've linked up
the ones that we could.
Now, we want the full
matrix, because for planning,
we want to know how many people
want to go from here to there.
So there are different
methods for scaling.
We have different situations.
So AFC, AVL, and ODX,
together, given an OD matrix,
but it's only for a
sample of passenger trips.
If you have APC, that gives
you the full boarding count
[AUDIO OUT].
So if you have that for all
your bus fleet, then great.
You can use IPF.
And you could apply your
ODX matrix as the seed
to make it more accurate.
That's great.
In some cases, you only have
APC on a fraction of vehicles
or on no vehicles.
And therefore, that's
a little tougher.
So IPF can be applied
in this context,
not just on the whole
matrix, but also
on the part of the matrix
that is not inferred.
So you can, essentially,
subtract from your control
totals the portion of the
demand that was inferred,
and apply IPF only
on the remainder.
And that will scale
up only that part.
OK?
That's better if you don't
want to distort your seed too
much, essentially.
If you're not very
comfortable assuming
that all the people
that are not inferred
have the same demand OD
structure as the people
that you do have
an inference for,
then separating
those out and using
IPF on the uninferred
portion will give you
a more accurate result
because you're not
amplifying whatever you
observed and was able to infer.
So one example of
that is transfers.
And we'll give an example of
that in the next few slides,
actually, right here.
So consider scaling when you
have transfer information
from ODX, and you don't
have APC on every bus.
You have it on some
buses, but not every bus.
So the real complete OD
matrix is what you want.
And we could split it.
I'm using algebraic
notation here.
The real matrix, R, can be
split into the inferred portion
and the missing portion, M.
And the missing portion--
there's two reasons
for missing data.
One of them is, I
saw the boarding,
but I couldn't
infer destination.
So that's U, the
uninferred portion.
And then there's the N,
the non-interaction part.
Those are the people
that board without
interacting with the fare box.
We want all of R. We know I, or
at least we made an inference
for I. And then we want to
estimate U and estimate N.
And then we can add those two
estimates together to the I,
and we'll have the estimate
of R. And that's what we want.
That's what scaling
accomplishes.
Now there's one critical
observation to make here.
If you take a trip
on a bus line,
and then you transferred
somewhere else,
there will be a tap close
to your destination,
shortly after your destination.
So the likelihood that
you were able to make
a destination inference is very
high Do you agree with that?
Yes or no?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
If you have some bus line,
and let's say that at stop
B, there is a rail station.
And you are taking the
bus line from D, C,
to B. If you are actually going
to transfer to this transfer
station, then you will
have a tap onto x, shortly
after you get off at B. Right?
OK.
So given that I inferred
your origin being D,
the probability that I actually
infer that your distinction was
B is very high because
I have the information
to make that inference.
It's close in time
and in distance.
It will pass the checks.
So if we make the assumption
that in every case where
we have a transfer,
we've successfully
inferred the destination, then
we have to then say, well,
then none of the people
who are uninferred
had a transfer afterwards.
Right?
OK.
And what happens with--
what if this is a very
popular rail station,
and a lot of people take it?
Then the uninferred
portion of the demand
are people who don't
transfer there.
And if you applied the
ODX matrix of the people
that you had a
destination inference for,
you would be weighing B as
the destination too much.
Those people are not very
likely transferring to--
some people might be getting
off at B, but fewer of them
because you're looking
at the people who
don't end up transferring.
So it could be people that
go somewhere else around B,
but the percentage
will be lower.
So what we want to do is produce
destination probability matrix
from the portion of I that
we inferred that was not
followed by a transfer.
So we prepare a
different matrix,
excluding the people that
transferred after this trip.
And then we use that to
scale up the remaining
origins in probability.
So that's what we have here,
expressed mathematically.
U is the vector of
boarding locations
with uninferred destinations.
And we multiply it
times L bar, where
L bar is a matrix of destination
probabilities of trips
not followed by transfers.
So that comes from
ODX, But we remove
trips followed by transfers.
All right?
And then we have to take care
of the non-interaction trips
or not observed trips.
Some of them are trips
with uninferred origins.
So it could be that we know that
this person was at this trip
because the origin
inference failed,
or it could be that the person--
there's some information
that, in general,
some portion of
passengers don't interact.
So you want to scale everything
up by 5%, say, as an example.
That could come from
surveys or from APC,
if you have APC on a
portion of the fleet.
So essentially, n, here,
is the scaling factor.
It could be bump what you have
so far, which is I plus U,
by some amount, some percentage.
That's the simple
way of doing it.
n could be a vector.
So you could have
different scaling factors
for each boarding stop.
It could be a 5%
overall, or it could
be there's a lot of
non-interaction at this stop,
but not this stuff stop.
It could be correlated to loads.
So many things could happen.
You can scale up this way.
And now we have
everything together.
So this is just
combining the terms.
This is the scaling
factor for not observed,
so if n is a flat
5%, this is 1.05.
And then I is what
you had from ODX.
And uL is the application of
the destinations improbability
to the people that had origins,
but not inferred destinations.
OK?
Questions about this
method, the scaling method?
This for one trip, or for
bus trips together, say.
It's not journey-level scaling.
So let's move on to
journey-level scaling.
So now we're getting a
little more complicated.
So we have journeys, which
include full itineraries
of people boarding
at one location,
or entering a station in one
location, doing several trips,
including transfers, possibly.
And each of those is
considered an itinerary.
An itinerary could be one stage,
or could be multiple stages
linked together with transfers.
So again, we have
inferred itineraries
for a portion of the demand.
But we want to scale up the
demand, knowing control totals,
but at the itinerary level,
because we have information
about itineraries.
So why not do it that way?
It could be more accurate.
So it's challenging because
there are many possibilities.
And some places that
people go through
don't have good control totals.
But essentially, we can
follow an approach that
is, in essence,
IPF but applied not
to boardings and alightings,
but to the scaling
factors themselves.
So this is a toy example.
Here's a rail line where
there's tap in and tap out.
Here's a bus line where
there's only tap in.
So there are many
possible itineraries
that a person could have here.
Going from A to
B, transfer to D,
alight at E, that's
one itinerary.
Go from A to C, through B,
that's another itinerary.
And at each of the nodes
here, A, B, C, D, E,
there might be some counts.
So on D and E, we only have on
counts because people are not
tapping off.
On A, B, and C, we have on and
off, or entry and exit, counts.
That means that there
are these count nodes, A
in, B out, as two
examples, where
we count how many people
go through that place.
And we know from--
we have, for a portion of the
people, this ODX sample here,
some number of itineraries that
go through A. So this is A in.
So we have some people going--
a portion of those
people are inferred
to have gone from A to
B, a portion to ABC,
a portion on the itinerary ABDE.
And then there's some portion
of it, shown here as delta A
in, who are included
in the counts,
but we don't have an
inference of their itinerary.
OK?
So what we want to do is
scale up the mixture of ODX
here to make up the
total entry count.
But there's a catch.
These itineraries are
affecting counts elsewhere
on the network.
So we also have B
out, as one example.
And we know that
the people on TAB
also show up on the count on
B, not the people going ABC,
though.
Those are not included
in the count of B
out because they
don't exit at B.
And there are some new
itineraries showing up at B out
that are not in A in.
So we want to somehow match
the counts at all the places
that are affected, or
that are showing up,
or associated with
each itinerary,
and scale the demand so
that the control totals are
satisfied at all locations.
So the method is similar to IPF.
We prepare a binary location
itinerary incidence matrix
with zeros and ones,
associating each itinerary
with the count nodes.
So A in, well, AB is one
itinerary that is shown there.
So is ABC, ABDE, not CB, not
CBDE, not DE, as an example.
So we have this big
matrix of zeros and ones.
And we have two equations.
Ti is the total scaled
up itinerary demand
on itinerary i.
And we know that
that total is going
to be 1 plus the scaling
factor, or the scaling factor
is 1 plus alpha, really.
Alpha is the portion
over 1 that we
want to scale by times the
observed or inferred flow
on that itinerary i, which is t.
Then we also have this other
relationship that the remaining
portion of the count on a node,
which is the count on node n,
the control total on
node n, minus the portion
that was seen through
that place is the amount--
it adds up to the sum
of all itineraries going
through that place times
their scaling factors.
So now we need to figure out
what the scaling factors are
for each itinerary, satisfying
both of these equations.
We have two
equations on vectors,
we have it on control nodes, and
we also have it on itineraries.
So we're back to
the same situation.
We can do IPF on
itineraries and count nodes.
And that's what we do.
If we have better data, we could
initialized with a good seed
matrix, otherwise you
could initialized to 1.
We then update the estimated
count nodes, which is delta.
Again, delta here
is the difference
between the count of
flow through that node
and the observed flow.
So it's the part that
you have to scale up to.
And you do that for all nodes.
And then you-- oh, let's
look at what happens here.
So when you apply this equation,
you calculate a delta hat
right here.
That is much higher,
it looks like.
Yeah, it's much higher than
the actual measured delta.
So you know that
that initial scaling
is producing demand flow that
is too high through those nodes.
And that's because
we said that alpha
was 1 for all of those nodes.
But it isn't, so those alphas
need to be adjusted now.
So we moved to alphas.
And we update alphas by
looking at, essentially,
the average scaling
factor required
across these control deltas
that apply to each itinerary.
Not all of them apply
to each itinerary.
So for itinerary
AB, you would take
the average required
adjustment factor
across all the deltas
that apply to AB,
which are only the first two.
You wouldn't include
the last three
because they don't touch AB.
So you calculate the average,
and you adjust the alphas.
But now you're not getting
the demand that you expected,
so you have to go back, and
you cycle through again.
And you go back and
forth, back and forth.
You apply these two
equations until you converge.
And convergence in this case
means that the delta hats
will match the deltas
that you measured,
and that the alpha
values are not changing
much between iterations.
OK?
So we haven't seen the
proof that this converges.
It relies on an average here.
So it's an introduction or
a new aspect of the method.
But in every test that
we've run, it does converge.
On a toy example,
where we didn't
know what the actual
journeys were,
because we produced
the real data,
and then we hit it,
and scaled it up,
we started with different
required scaling factors
by itinerary.
So in the blue line case,
this blue line right here,
the scaling factors
required across itineraries
were very similar to each other.
They all needed to be scaled
up by the same amount.
And what we show here is
that the solution converged
very quickly, and that
the accuracy was high,
because the root mean
squared error was low.
OK?
But then as we start
moving to differences
in scaling factors
required, the algorithm
did converge and
produced different alphas
for each itinerary.
But it took longer to
converge, and the root
mean square of
the final solution
was higher, which makes sense.
All these methods, the
IPF founding methods
amplify errors.
They amplify whatever you
give it at the beginning.
So if you start with
something all 1's and in fact,
they are quite different from
1's or some of them are 1,
and others are not, then
you're going to have a bigger
error in the final solution.
So this was applied
to London once again.
In practice, there is
another complication.
People who are
counted at each node,
they don't all finish
their journeys,
or they don't all start their
journeys in the time band
that you are including
the counts in.
So if you do a trip
that takes a whole hour,
you might be seeing
tapping in here,
and then you might end up
tapping out at the next hour.
So you need control totals,
in this case, by the hour.
We were looking at hour scaling,
scaling of demand every hour.
But you need to adjust
the control totals to get
what percentage of people
who are tapping out
at this location
actually started
their journey in that hour.
How many of them actually
started on the hour before?
So there was an
offset correction,
and this is what is
being shown here.
Here you have raw entries and
raw exits in dashed lines.
And the correction essentially
shifted those entries
backwards in time a little
bit, so that the control totals
matched.
And then you can run the journey
scaling as we just showed.
And the results, we don't have
ground truth data in this case.
You could run a survey.
I guess LTDS, in some
ways, is ground truth,
but it's a low sample.
The overall scaling
required was about 50%.
You can see the 3/2 line here.
One way of validating it
was to run it only on rail.
Because rail has OND, we can
run IPF on the rail matrix,
because you have the control
totals for all the gates
in and out.
So there's no
complication of the bus.
You can run IPF on that.
And it aligned very well with
the more sophisticated solution
of running this by proportional
fitting on the itinerary
scaling factors, instead
of the simpler IPF method.
Presumably, the errors
that you see here
that are slightly
off the diagonal
are improvements in accuracy.
Because instead of starting
from, say, all 1's you
are using good information
about a seed matrix from ODX.
So the accuracy should
have been improving.
We don't have, again, the ground
truth to assert that measure,
how close are we
about to reality.
And one application
of this, here's
a chart showing all the origins.
So it's like a
heat map of London.
And a darker color of
red shading each cell
shows a higher
proportion of people
originating at that location and
going to Oxford Circus, which
is right here in the middle.
So for a planner,
looking at this
and knowing if I
want to know where
people are coming from to
Oxford circle, here's a map.
And you can do is by time band,
so only for the AM peak or--
there's many applications of
this origin destination data.
I'm just showing you one here.
And here are some references,
so Jay Gordon's thesis,
a paper he wrote.
The Southwick reference is
for the scaling of buses
without the transfer demand.
So if you want to
read more about that,
that's the write up.
And then I wrote a
paper on the inference
of destinations using
dynamic programming,
instead of closest node.
That's also published.
You can get that.
And then finally,
Jay's website has
the this visualizations for
London, and Boston, and yeah.
So you can have fun
looking at that.
All right.
Do we have any
questions about this?
We can watch the
animations again.
And maybe now we really know--
now we really appreciate
what went into it.
AUDIENCE: So I know
there's a number
of old systems [AUDIO OUT]
a lot of newer systems
are just doing proof of payment.
So in that case,
they only can use--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
So some new systems
are proof of payment as well.
AUDIENCE: Right.
And in that case, they
can only use APC to--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
So right.
You can have APC.
APC has some issues, especially
when the vehicle is crowded.
Some people block APC sensors.
So you could have--
if it's proof of
payment, manual surveys
is the other alternative.
Yeah.
And proof of payment is
something we can debate.
It has benefits and [AUDIO OUT].
So on the data
collections side, that's
a clear disadvantage
of proof of payment.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So for the scaling--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Which scaling method?
AUDIENCE: The slide 41
GABRIEL
SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: 41, OK.
AUDIENCE: You've got an
itinerary and an itinerary, so
how many itineraries
do you have?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Oh many, many, many, many.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Any possible combination of--
I don't know if
I have that here.
AUDIENCE: This is only
one example of one trip.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Yeah, so--
AUDIENCE: So you have--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
So we know
that there are
trillions of solutions
that satisfy the control total.
I forget how many
unique itineraries there
are, but many, many, many.
It's a large number in a city
like London, particularly.
AUDIENCE: So for
this method, you--
GABRIEL
SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: So this
is a computationally
intense activity.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You need
the APC information.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
On bus, you
would want to have that.
That would be one control total
that you could use for bus.
This method is flexible,
though, because it
doesn't require that you have
control totals everywhere.
You just use whatever
control total you trust.
So say, if you didn't
have APC on buses,
then you would only use
the control total on rail.
If you have APC
on some buses, you
could use the control
totals on those buses
to improve the
scaling information.
But it doesn't require that
all the places have counts.
Does that make sense?
Because you have, essentially,
a list of count nodes.
And that list is not necessarily
a complete list of places
that people go through.
And then you have all the list
of itineraries that you see,
and you want to associate those.
Again, no proof of
convergence here.
But [AUDIO OUT].
And on the toy
examples we run, we
observe these properties of
convergence rate and error
at the end, which is consistent
with normal or more traditional
applications of IPF.
So we can hypothesize that
it behaves very similarly.
Question in the back.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] generate a
list of reasonable itineraries.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
It's not
a list of reasonable
itineraries.
It's a list of
inferred itineraries.
So it's an area
that was inferred
because I saw you
tapping in here,
out there, then transferring,
taking this bus,
and maybe you took three
other buses after that.
Maybe one person did that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
That's one itinerary
that's included here.
AUDIENCE: So do we just
ignore the possibility
that the people with
uninferred destinations have--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Something different?
Yes.
You could generate
every combination,
but that's maybe intractable.
So what we're doing
is only considering
itineraries that were observed,
and only scaling those up.
But that's a good point.
There might be some
people that were counted,
but didn't have an inference,
and their itinerary
might be completely different.
And this method
doesn't handle that.
AUDIENCE: How different is
[AUDIO OUT] the scaling matrix,
compared with the traditional
matrix that you can calculate
with the sample [INAUDIBLE]
to infer the alighting?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
You mean the traditional IPF?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Are you [INAUDIBLE]?
Is it very different?
Or is--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: No.
Well, it depends on the
accuracy of your IPF procedure
and the accuracy of
your control totals.
Yeah, if your seed
matrix is very good,
then IPF should
[AUDIO OUT] well.
[AUDIO OUT] any applications
of IPF, we just seed it to one
and run it.
And you have the issue
of the transfer, which
would plague that, and it
would amplify the error
because presumably,
your seed matrix--
a lot of people might be
getting off here to transfer,
and you may not be
considering that.
If you use IPF to scale
up the inferred portion,
for example, that would happen.
So I think through
our validation,
we have seen that
there's more reason
to trust the inference
algorithms scaled
up than to just take control
totals and scale those up.
From an information
theory perspective,
we're adding information,
so you should--
even if we can't provide
evidence that absolutely, it
is the case, from
information theory,
we see we're consuming
more information
to generate this estimate,
then that the estimate
should be more accurate.
But it depends on whether your
inferences were correct or not.
That depends on the assumptions
you made about people.
So many assumptions
go into this,
and it's hard to say exactly.
All right.
So do you want to
look at Boston?
Or--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Let's see.
Turn it off.
All right, so here's Boston.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
It's a much smaller city.
And this is an earlier
video where we still
had some issues with ODX.
And so some of them,
you could perhaps
detect by looking
at the animation.
So that's another
application of this animation
is to find issues
with the algorithm.
In this case, people
are being routed
through the actual paths.
So that's another difference
between the video of London,
where people were
bursting in linearly.
AUDIENCE: Right.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Here, it looks less bursty,
and part of that is that the
nodes are moving through paths.
AUDIENCE: You see these thick
dots along the red line.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Some of the issues are
very slowly-moving dots.
So you see some green
dots that barely move.
So those are errors that
have been fixed already,
and we should run
this program again
to generate a new animation
without those errors.
But yeah, you see
the same pattern.
This is now late at night.
So you can see where people
are still at work, or perhaps
at restaurants, or bars.
And Boston system
just shuts down.
So it's not as alive at night
because we're only looking
at people who would take the T.
All right?
Thank you.
And if you have
questions, I'll take them.
Otherwise, I'll
see you next class.